en colombia el 2020 será recordado no
sólo por la pandemia sino también por
ser uno de los años más sangrientos en
el registro el nuevo reporte de la alta
comisionada de la onu para los derechos
humanos mostró que en los últimos meses
ha habido casi el doble de masacres que
el año pasado ya que en 2020 se
registraron 66 matanzas comparadas con
las 36 que confirmó la onu en 2019
además los muertos también se duplicaron
y van a cometer por género de alta
comisionada a las naciones unidas para
los derechos humanos michelle bachelet
condena la intensificación de la
violencia que están llevando a cabo los
grupos armados no estatales los grupos
criminales y otros elementos armados en
colombia contra los campesinos indígenas
y afrocolombianos y pidió a las
autoridades estatales tomar acciones
concretas para proteger eficazmente a la
población de population aunque las
estadísticas de la onu son escandalosas
son aún más conservadoras que las de la
ong colombiana indepaz que sostiene que
en el país ha habido 84 masacres
incluida la más reciente del pasado
domingo
se confirma la masacre 84 del 2020
comunicado de las autoridades
tradicionales indígenas de colombia
gobierno mayor la comunidad indica que
un grupo ilegal de la guajira asesinó al
líder de la comunidad indígena wayú
alacat a tres comuneros indígenas y
dejaron varios heridos en lo que sí
coinciden los registros es en que la
violencia se ha enquistado
particularmente contra los indígenas tan
solo la etnia nasa contabiliza a 66
indígenas asesinados en el suroeste del
país de acuerdo con la onu los grupos
armados han matado tantos miembros de
pueblos autóctonos que hace dos meses
los indígenas marcharon de diferentes
regiones de colombia hacia bogotá la
capital para pedir que les respeten la
vida y los territorios el gobierno no se
ha pronunciado sobre el nuevo reporte de
naciones unidas'